can i just say
it's a matter of this amount of of of
choices yeah my brother there he's made
his decision everything whether i agree
or not i have to afterwards don't agree
i have to respect that because i'm
trying to live my life differently in it
but obviously i respect one thing i
always advocate for is everyone has the
freedom to to live their life the way
they the way they want to i just want to
come back um to
to the original question a bit more um
because
this um this question is very um
is very personal to me because i've
actually like lived through this
experience so um
um wait was the question again
so if you have if you have more if
you're making more money
and your partner
steps out yeah
okay cool so the person that's making
the money making the money if they step
out would you stay with the breadwinner
okay so
from the time
from the time when i was like 16 yeah
every
every girl every woman i was interested
in i always said to them yeah i'm going
to have a lot of money it's like from 16
i already knew i said i'm gonna have a
lot of money i'm gonna this is what i'm
gonna do i'm gonna have a wonderful life
this than any other so i need you
to i don't
i don't want that to to kind of shake
you you know to kind of like if you
don't i don't come for money
come from very poor background but i
already knew my destiny so
i didn't i don't want someone who's
going to be shaken by that right so with
that being said
i'm now
the breadwinner yeah i'm professional
footballer i'm a keynote speaker i'll do
this that in the other right
i personally wouldn't make
me personally i personally wouldn't make
the decision to step out all right
for me it's been it's been the reversal
when i was with someone yo i was doing
the madness for this person like
spending crazy money crazy on this
person
and then they still cheated do you know
why so
now that i'm finished i'll tell you why
yeah yeah they
they they actually told me that they
want to go with my boy
but um but yeah that's a story for
another thing
you know why do you know why because you
didn't put no boundaries on it and you
were spoiling it too much it was
probably you probably put on a pedestal
bro deserve it well nah she definitely
deserve it brother how can she deserve
it she cheated
dude i just i just want to say like the
the emotional damage that came from that
i remember exactly like when it was like
the fifth of january at 10 22 like like
10 22 yeah
[Laughter]
it was crazy because like i was i was i
was
a lot younger and naive then but i
didn't sleep that night i remember it
was like around 3am i was shaking i went
to the living room i was at my parents
house i went to the living room and mom
had to come out come out the house like
yo like what's going on with you i'm
like
and um
how old do we
it happened a couple of times
so the first
the first time it happened
i was in my i was in my late teens i
think
same person right i was same person yeah
same person gave her another chance i
gave another chance
but the thing you know
it sounds like even me now it sounds
like saying it says like wow
why why why did you do that but you know
like like as a man yeah when you when
you love a woman bro like you want to
like you want to do everything for her
you go online you see what what everyone
else is doing for their women and you
want you're trying to you're trying to
be that man you know you're trying to be
that and try try to tell her that listen
i got you no matter what i got you you
know um
so
yeah the first time it happened i was
completely heartbroken uh mom came my
mom came to me at 3am like yo what's
wrong with what's wrong with you i told
her what happened everything
um it it it it completely completely
broke me but then i went back to that
girl again you know was she was she a
virgin
no she wasn't girl um
at the time she was
and then she cheated
to you
but i didn't say how would she wait wait
wait wait i didn't say she had sex
though
what she said she cheated oh she gave
she gave her oh she had
yeah it's like respect the boundary
he's not going to
um
point being um it happened um
uh went back to her and then um
it happened again so then at this point
i'm just like okay
um enough is enough kind of like i can't
i know that i'm a good brother you know
i know that i'm not i'm not out here
doing the most i'm trying to be i'm
trying to be a good brother so if you
can't respect that then you have to
bounce you have to bounce you know but
my point all my point i'm trying to make
is yeah
everyone has a choice to make right i
made that choice to go back to this
particular somebody um
i made a choice to go back to her and
whatever followed followed didn't it so
in everything i was saying yeah i just
want everyone to to to have this in mind
yeah that everything that you do will
have a consequence at the end of it
whether you like it or not everything
will have a consequence so
you i'm not saying no one should live
the life man because i've i've lived
i've lived my life which brings me to my
point brother like what you said um what
did you say that i'll get eat in a
second
yeah you're good
okay okay i'm six foot three i'm tall
i'm dark i'm handsome i've i've i've
been
tested bro i've been tested i moved out
my first time moved up my parents house
i was 16 yeah moved to southampton yeah
um i was
like take this quick story here
i moved that i was 16. um i was balling
um the team gave me a place
had my own place i had
had somewhat of freedom i had them so we
were staying in what we call digs like
if you don't know football like when
you're playing for an academy show you
stay in digs and then you have like
someone that just looks after you kind
of comes around cooks for you and
everything
um kind of yeah but luckily i my mom
already taught me how to do all of that
so she wasn't she didn't need her to
come to come around much um but then um
i had
a group of a particular group of friends
at the time that that were not so good
for me you know just our goals and and
our beliefs didn't align so then what
they did is they got
um they they they got someone to
basically try to try to to trap me we
were talking about men being trapped um
so they said to her like um
basically go to his place and and try to
you know try to seduce him what not so
um
she came yeah she knocked on the door
and i i knew who she was because we were
all friends at the time she knocked on
the door yeah and
when i say this girl was fire
fit
fine
nice lang
with the buns everything bro everything
she was so nice so she not to the door i
was trembling i'm like oh my gosh what's
happening here not because she was
dressed like she was ready to attack
yeah so she was like
you said trembling that's the words you
used i was trembling bro let me i was
trembling you were probably you were
probably like you'll probably like take
that situation and take control of the
situation no no no no no no no i mean
i'm just i'm just like
i love it at the time i'm saying i love
him bro
i was trembling i'm thinking my lord
what's happening here she came in
walks in remember correctly she walks in
she shuts the door behind her locks and
switches off the light so immediately
yeah you love that look at his waist my
brother
eyes closed and everything um so
immediately i knew that okay i'm in a
situation here
i knew that okay i'm in a situation here
obviously um
through the use
kids these days would grow up quickly so
i already knew what was happening but i
didn't know how to deal with it at the
time so she came in and they're like
yeah this is what's happening this then
the other stretches of the light and
only only god knows how i got out of
that house imagine like it's my place
here but i leave her in the house and i
run outside
yeah
that's that's that that that
all right all i'm saying
the gun
wait how do you no hang on i hear you
and this is the whole thing is that
this is why i said you're going to get
eaten alive because there's women that
know how to do this type of stuff no no
no i don't think so because if i was to
get if i was to be eaten alive yeah i
would have been eaten alive because
that's just one example it's happened
multiple times bro like can i speak i
can't let him i'm living
laurie is interested bro
what happened
and he's saying he didn't get run up on
you got run upon bro what galen want
from you is your resources bro like they
don't necessarily want their
phila mignon to be filling me
but i'm saying to you well he's talking
about he's talking about the fact that
someone tried to set
him up
i get that but i'm saying to you
there necessarily is not okay their game
is not necessarily to to sleep with you
bro they haven't no they want to sleep
with me they want to sleep with me bro
yo that's what i'm trying to say
they're two different stories two
different stories i'm talking about bro
let the guy finish
um um yeah i ran up the house and um but
my point being that was just one
situation in it because i'm trying to
i'm almost trying to defend myself in a
way where i know that i'm not going to
be eaten i've been with women bro
like if
if i will show you the women that that
i've been with bro they're they're
they're not you know i mean they're
they're they're not those things so
they're models they're they're youtubers
i can't name them obviously they're the
big personalities like
my question is though so why would you
go for that type of woman knowing the
type of man that you are i was young bro
right i was young but that's the thing
that i was young i had this
this
narrative of of of of how i wanted to
live my life and my thing is yeah i'm
thinking to myself i'm going to be a big
star i'm going to do this i'm going to
do that i want someone that comes from
from from from that background as well
yeah but the thing is with in wanting
that you have to know that this person
there's nothing wrong with having
someone that's that's in the same field
domain as you're never in the bush
but the thing is yeah the thing is yeah
there's nothing wrong yeah we've wanted
something
yeah my point is yes good point fair
point i could my point is nothing wrong
with going with that kind of caliber of
women yeah but um it's more about the
the person's um characteristics traits
yeah because people look at me and i'm
i'm so tired of like speaking about this
and defending but i have to continue
doing this because the first thing
whenever i went for years
wait i'm trying to think of the timeline
now i went through a period yeah where i
just couldn't i came on social media
came on social media um delayed all my
accounts because it just it just got
ridiculously too much yeah and i got to
a point where like every time i had to
defend myself like whenever i told
someone like i'm a footballer if i'll
tell if i meet a woman i was like okay
what do you do for a living i say i'm a
footballer immediately i'm cancelled
because they know that footballers are
this footballers are um for indian
america are you serious mm-hmm not
professional professional i played four
links i've seen jupiter prem
what abroad abroad yeah oh brother
yeah i live in spain oh you live in
spain okay
so you're in the la liga
uh
now now i live in spain last year i was
playing in japan that's in japan i was
living and playing in india oh okay yeah
but now i'm in um
uh i'm in the middle of getting a
transfer um which i can't i don't think
i'm like right you're like saying all
right
right now but um but yeah if you follow
me on socials and you'll follow my
journey um
um point being is like i always felt as
if i had to like defend myself all the
time like okay although
this is what i do for a living because
this is not what this is not who i
a known am
bro exactly exactly sadly a lot a lot of
um
athletes in general man a lot of
athletes have have the way they've been
depicted in media is not very pleasant
so those of us who are trying to change
the narrative we have a very very
difficult task because it's hard to find
someone that would then believe you the
same way that i shared my secret head
and everyone's like
you know what i mean because it's like
no no way it can't be sold but point
being is so so in in
in that regard you have to more so focus
on the person's personality the
characteristic traits the values the
morals and what they stand for instead
of how much they make and all that other
rhetoric